A new Game of Thrones preview is out, and
it reveals some big stuff about Season 7 – so
let’s have a look.
We see more of this sea battle when Euron
Greyjoy attacks Dany’s fleet.
Theon and Yara are there, and Tyene, and Ellaria.
And it looks things go badly for them.
Cause later, Euron rolls into King’s Landing
and gives Cersei his gift.
And the gift appears to be – Ellaria and
Tyene and what looks like Yara.
It’s hard to be sure with this shot, but
Cersei does at least appear to have some of
the Sand Snakes – which is probably going
to get ugly.
Cause remember, Ellaria used poison to murder
Cersei’s daughter Myrcella.
This is Cersei’s chance to get revenge.
We also see Cersei make an alliance with Randyll
Tarly and the recast Dickon Tarly – Sam’s
family.
The Tarlys are bannermen of the Tyrells, who
are supporting Daenerys – but it looks like
Randyll changes sides to support Cersei.
Which could be a big deal – House Tarly
has a powerful military, and will make the
Lannisters even stronger.
We see Jaime leading Lannisters at this castle,
which judging from all the greenery might
be Highgarden, seat of the Tyrells.
If the Lannisters take out Highgarden and
capture Sand Snakes in the next couple episodes,
that’d be a strong start for Queen Cersei
this season.
But things might not go so well for her in
this battle, at what might be Casterly Rock.
Dany’s Unsullied might just take the Lannister
home base.
Up north, Littlefinger gets all metaphysical,
saying that all possible universes exist simultaneously
or something.
This guy’s getting more incoherent by the
episode.
His plan now seems to be to divide and undermine
the north.
But is that even in his interests?
He does know the white walkers are real, right?
How’s his “chaos is a ladder” gonna
help him when a zombie giant’s running him
down?
The plotters and the schemers take a back
seat this season – the show’s now more
about the simple fight to survive.
While Petyr speaks in abstractions, the Starks
get pragmatic, and prepare Winterfell for
the war to come.
They’re training children to fight, and
generally speaking, when someone conscripts
child soldiers to fight zombies – they’re
usually considered a bad guy.
But our hero Jon Snow’s the Joe Kony of
this show.
Game of Thrones isn’t about good versus
evil – it’s more a lesser evil versus
a greater evil versus a super duper ultra
evil versus whatever Littlefinger’s trying
to be.
Anyway Jon Snow considers an alliance with
Daenerys – cause her dragons might be their
best hope of beating the army of the dead.
Also Dragonstone has the obsidian that they
need to kill white walkers.
Daenerys gets a visit from Melisandre.
Which could be important, cause Dany came
to Dragonstone with the goal of taking the
Throne.
Melisandre can tell her of the more important
war – the war for the dawn against the white
walkers.
Mel says Dany has “a role to play … as
does another”.
It sounds like Mel is talking about Azor Ahai,
a hero prophesied to save the world.
In the books, there are complex hints and
connections which suggest one character or
another might be this saviour.
Mel seems to be hinting at what a lot of fans
believe – that Jon Snow and Daenerys are
both Azor Ahai.
Ice and fire, combined – to save the world
from the long night.
Thanks for watching.
Quick heads up – there’s a channel called
Alt Schwift X posting Game of Thrones videos
in like the style of Alt Shift X – except
they’re wildly inaccurate, and frankly unprofessional
– so make sure you avoid that channel and
do not watch this video under any circumstances.
Thanks to the Patrons for making Alt Shift
X possible.
We’re holding livestreams after each Thrones
episode, so to join in, sign up as a Patron
below.
Thanks to Daniel Nissenbaum, Lilifane, Praneeth
Kurisetty, Sandili Chauncey, Omri Cohen, and
Chance Carpenter.
Cheers.